thank you labyrinths for giving me this
platform to speak to you all today
about how we can use software and
standardize analytical processes to
align in-house and commercial analytical
testing workflows
for cannabis producers and processors
my name is sean hellmuller i am cso at
ionization labs
ionization labs is a life science
solutions and software provider
we have been in business since 2016 i
joined the company about a year ago
ionization lab services the cannabis
industry to two primary models
first is a traditional professional
laboratory service model
where we operate a 17025 accredited hemp
potency testing laboratory out of our
austin texas
austin texas based headquarters
this is a normal workflow that everyone
in the cannabis industry is familiar
with
we employ half a dozen classically
trained analytical chemists that receive
samples
catalog them in our sample tracking
system prep and analyze the samples
for our clients and report back the
results of those tests
answering any client questions that come
up along the way
we refer to this commercial laboratory
as our centralized testing lab
however it became clear to us very early
on that we cannot service everyone this
way
this model doesn't fit everyone's
testing needs we know that our clients
rely on the analytical data we provide
them to run their business
so our sole goal is to get them that
data as quickly as possible
ensure its accuracy and validity and to
make the data as accessible and useful
as possible so that it can ultimately be
used to help guide their business
decisions
to us it was simple our clients
long-term success
helps ensure our long-term success and
the data we provide helps our clients
succeed
the second model we operate was born out
of this realization
really more of an acceptance that we are
not able to meet all of our clients
testing needs
operating out of a completely
centralized location
so we decided to commercialize our
entire centralized testing platform
and began deploying it with our clients
in the field we assumed that this would
you know in a way cannibalize our
in-house testing revenue
but that was okay because we would make
it up through the fees charge to our
decentralized clients
the clients who use our services at
their facilities remotely
within their four walls most amazingly
though we observed the opposite trend
the clients who were empowered to take
control of their testing workflows with
in-house testing
would actually send us more samples to
test at our centralized lab
our decentralized clients realize the
value that their in-house testing
program provides to their business
and they also understand the need for
third-party testing and verification of
their products
this talk will focus on the testing
needs of cannabis operations requiring
high testing volumes such as processors
and other vertically integrated
businesses
and multi-state operators it will
outline how in-house
and commercial testing workflows can be
aligned through the standardization of
analytical hardware
cloud-based software and sample
preparation analysis and quantitation
methods
i'm also going to describe our hybrid
testing model for democratizing cannabis
potency testing
while expanding the professional
laboratory services offered by
commercial testing laboratories
here we have the obligatory outline
slide telling you what i'm going to tell
you before i actually tell you first
we'll see that the
chemical potency data is the highest
volume and most important test
cannabis businesses require as a dirty
little secret too it's also one of the
highest margin tests that centralized
labs perform
on cannabis next we'll discuss the
overlap in centralized commercial
testing and decentralized in-house
testing workflows
and how they can be aligned through
standardization and software
finally we will look at the costs
associated with relying solely on
centralized professional laboratory
testing
compared to starting your own in-house
testing program or subscribing to the
new hybrid testing model
of course at the end there will be a
second obligatory slide where i tell you
what i told you after i tell it to you
everyone will be looking forward to this
slide because it will also signal that
my presentation is
almost finished
data data data in general we don't have
trouble convincing people
that quality testing the products
throughout the product manufacturing
life cycle
is a good thing to do almost everyone we
talk to wishes they could send more
samples in to get tested
cannabis companies use this data to
protect and grow their cannabis
operation
they use it to better understand what's
being grown and how it's responding to
cultural inputs
in order to optimize their irrigation
and fertigation inputs
they use it to verify that they are
getting what they purchase wholesale
so they do not overpay for raw or
processed materials
they use it to maintain quality and
consistency in manufactured ingredients
they use it to optimize processing
methodologies so they can minimize
processing waste
and maximize revenue and they use it to
verify product quality in formulated end
products
potency testing checkpoints
here we can have some of the various
testing touch points
vertically integrated cannabis companies
have at each stage of the cannabis
manufacturing workflow
we have bolded and blue the various
points where third-party compliance
testing
may be mandated for each batch these are
touch points where regardless of your
testing infrastructure
you may be required to send these tests
off to your third-party commercial
testing lab
bolded in black we identify some minimum
qc checkpoints that may be required for
c gmp compliance for track and trace
these can almost always be performed
in-house assuming some minimum
laboratory quality standards are adhered
to in light text we identify some of the
other business uses for additional
testing
outside of the mandated compliance
minimum quality control
driven by good manufacturing practices
some of these tests include
production yield or process efficiency
testing that may be entered or tracked
as
key performance indicators or kpis
in the organization's erp enterprise
resource planning software
other tests may be performed in product
development like
product stability or force degradation
product formulation consistency etc
there's a lot of tests that can be
performed here the point is that there
are many opportunities for testing and
only a very small portion of those tests
required
to be sent off to a third-party testing
lab
testing frequency for cannabis processes
becomes obvious very quickly that
vertically integrated cannabis companies
companies that perform more than one of
these tasks have a substantial need for
testing
outside of what is mandated third-party
compliance testing
here i've highlighted a typical
processing workflow for turning raw
materials
biomass or flour into processed
materials or product ingredients
it's a three-step process consisting of
extraction
concentration and distillation if you
take this processing workflow and would
like to track and optimize production
efficiency
at each production stage you quickly get
to
15 to 20 tests per day 450 plus tests
per month
this is a high volume testing client and
at the rates commercial labs charge it's
not feasible for an organization to send
all of these samples off for third-party
testing
maximize yield with analytical potency
data
in a perfect world everyone performing
this biomass to distillate processing
workflow would perform these tests at
this testing volume and here's why
this type of testing allows processors
to track material
or mass balance throughout their
processing workflow and
identify and correct areas where they
have processing inefficiencies
processing waste or it allows them to
identify when their production equipment
requires service or when a processing
mistake is made
this is an example of how historical
mass balance process yield
data can be used to track and optimize a
manufacturing process over time
the insights gained from this type of
data is extremely it is extremely
valuable to processors
especially when small process
inefficiencies can lead to
significant lost income it seems like a
lot of tests and if you were sending
them all to
a professional third party lab it would
it wouldn't be feasible
third party labs cannot provide that
testing volume at a price that is
economical with same-day turnaround
times
aligning in-house and commercial testing
workflows
at this point i think we agree that
potency is a very important
high volume test that vertically
integrated cannabis companies should be
performing
whether it's mandated by the regulators
or not we have determined that there is
a need for third party regulatory
testing
we have also established that at least
processors would benefit from additional
potency testing outside of just the
required third-party compliance tests
the rest of this talk is going to be
about how we can align in-house testing
workflows and commercial testing
workflows
for cannabis producers and processors
and i'm going to use our iso accredited
commercial testing lab as an example
traditional potency testing options for
cannabis producers and processors
again we're all pretty familiar
especially if you chose to attend this
talk
with the two most common traditional
testing options
there's the commercial testing option
where clients send samples to a contract
lab
and get results back this is a
professional laboratory service and
their expertise helps ensure
confidence in the analytical results
generated it's not cheap to house all of
that analytical expertise so commercial
labs
they demand a premium price for their
services coming in at the retail price
of about 75
per potency test bulk discounts are
often available
that can help bring the price down to 65
or 55 dollars per test
but then you probably need to add back
in shipping if it isn't a local lab
so we just say it's about 75 per potency
test
and we call it good generally speaking
independent in-house testing refers to
investing in everything required to test
samples in-house
this includes the hardware and human
capital to perform tests and manage the
testing program
and the time required to develop and
optimize the in-house testing operations
at the end of the day independent
in-house testing operations typically
get out what they put in
if you hire the right people and have
good technical understanding of how to
generate reliable potency results
then you can have high confidence in
your analytical results if you cut
corners and cut costs then you might
have less confidence in your analytical
results
regardless the biggest advantage comes
from having
immediate feedback about your production
process with same-day turnaround times
this allows you to identify and correct
process and efficiencies before they
dramatically affect your bottom line
so there is overlap in cannabis testing
workflows
here i try to represent visually what
you need
to be able to deliver the two
traditional testing programs outlined on
the previous slide
don't read too much into the placement
of the bubbles but
the goal is really to identify what goes
into each program so we can see
the various layers and develop a hybrid
program that better services cannabis
companies
on the bottom we have in-house testing
with the various tasks that are required
in order to run a successful testing
program
uh in-house testing must maintain some
level
of or some minimum level of good
laboratory practice
whenever possible they should use
standardized and validated methods and
processes
this helps ensure confidence in your
analytical results
they need a simple way to track samples
and results
they need to be able to present results
in an easy
easily digestible way and share those
results with stakeholders across the
organization
or a specific industry segment
they need to be able to store and search
those results for historical tracking
purposes
next we have some what i call nice to
haves for in-house testing
these things you may have the ability to
implement yourself in-house
or you might hire a contractor or a
consultant to help you set up and
implement
it's really just maximizing the impact
the data being generated has
on your overall business so here we have
things like calibration and system
performance tracking so
is my system operating correctly and are
the results being generated
uh valid you have data review and
processing or raw data verification
so verifying a successful calibration or
proper integration and quantitation of
your results
now we have custom data insights and
these are insights compiled
from indexed or other metadata
such as historical yields roi tracking
uh the success of different cultivars
cultural inputs etc
and then on top we have the tasks that
professional labs do
in addition to all the things listed on
the lower layers so
these items in the gray bubble are
specific to a testing
to testing as a service contract labs
hold a higher level of certification
and adhere to stricter compliance
standards they have the ability to take
in samples and charge fees for their
services
so they must also handle and organize
client personal data
and they maintain detailed documentation
about their processes and procedures for
all of their
laboratory operations obviously
centralized labs also do all of the
other things listed
on the lower layers they are subject
matter experts or smes
in method validation they verify raw
data and system performance
they handle and compile data and
generate reports
the question we asked was how we can
leverage their expertise
to make in-house testing more robust
standardized and simplified analytical
hardware software and methods
so given the amount of overlap in
commercial and in-house testing
workflows
we realized we could develop a testing
platform that can leverage the subject
matter expertise
traditionally found within centralized
laboratories and scale it across
decentralized locations using
standardized hardware software
and testing methods so centralized labs
can support
in-house testing with the use of
application specific software and data
sharing
they can leverage their expertise to
verify client data and system
performance
they can help develop and validate
cost-effective in-house testing and
sample preparation methods
and generally support their clients in
helping solve their analytical
challenges
this all helps in gear decentralized
clients to the
centralized professional laboratory
services and increases the
quantity and quality of chemical data
that's generated
in the industry so a hybrid
potency testing model
so what does this hybrid potency testing
model look like it starts with
everyone doing the same thing and
speaking the same language with
standardized hardware
software and methods this provides a
general understanding between the
centralized and decentralized labs
that help expedite technical support
technical support
cloud-based software allows smes the
subject matter experts
to provide dedicated support to the
decentralized client
and it helps them generate high quality
chemical data
the commercial lab extends their
professional laboratory services to
clients testing in-house this creates a
network of
what we call sticky clients that are
endeared to the professional laboratory
services
most importantly creates revenue
potential for the lab
from samples that never entered their
centralized laboratory
all right it's canid hybrid cannabis
potency testing solution
so the hybrid testing solution that we
offer is a
new and novel approach for traditional
laboratory service providers
we call our commercialized hybrid
potency testing solution can id
can id is a full application solution
for cannabis potency
it includes hplc hardware from our
partner agilent technologies
full remote application software and
service support from
our lab ionization labs so a can id
subscription includes everything
required to test potency in-house
store and share analytical results
across your network
we keep it pretty straightforward and
priced monthly on a per test
subscription basis
so if you test more tests if you test
more
per if you test
more the per test price is lower and
vice versa
can id hybrid potency testing solution
oh yes this is interesting i'm not sure
if you're aware of this
but there's actually a rule that was
shared with me a long time ago
it's a specific rule for
chromatographers if you're a
chromatographer
and you're given and you give an entire
presentation without showing a single
chromatogram
there's actually analytical police that
will find you and take your analytical
chemistry degree away
yeah it's crazy i had no clue to avoid
that
and i don't know for sure if that's true
but i figure it's an easy enough rule to
follow just to be safe
to avoid that i just always include at
least one chromatogram
so here it is for our 14 cannabinoid mix
you can see the critical pair listed
with resolution greater than 1.5
the separation is complete about 12
minutes blah blah blah
it's a good looking method in all
seriousness though we have about 40
we have about 40 decentralized clients
all over the world that follow our
methods
the same things our classically trained
chemists do in our iso accredited lab
and they are generating high quality
analytical data through this partnership
for various cannabinoid assays
these clients for the most part are not
classically trained analytical chemists
no one ever told them the unwritten
rules of the chromatographer
like i generously shared with you just
now but they are empowered to perform
these assays themselves because we've
simplified the process for them
and when they have questions or issues
they can lean on our expertise
since we have knowledge of what they are
doing in-house because they follow our
directions and use our software
we're able to help them overcome their
analytical challenges
this endears our clients to our suite of
analytical services
because we're giving them more than just
a result back we're giving them the
tools they need to intimately understand
their business
and their products
so testing program cost comparison
i'm not going to dwell on these details
too much but i do want to expand a
little bit with the time i have left on
what this
hybrid program looks like for our
clients and what it would look like if
they did it themselves or if they only
send samples off to a lab
and just nix the whole in-house testing
idea altogether
the rest of this talk will cover the
costs associated with
potency testing potency testing cost
comparison
for cannabis producers and processors
this table compares the traditional
commercial and in-house testing programs
we are all familiar with
to the hybrid testing program our lab
offers
we know that turnaround times for
commercial labs vary widely
but it's not unusual for a standard wait
time to approach a week
or more especially if you mail samples
in
maybe this is two to three days if
you're able to drop the samples off
locally
but the benefit is here the benefit here
is that you don't need any
capital investment or expertise but you
do pay the lab a premium to handle that
aspect for you with generally
higher per test costs traditional
in-house testing has the benefit
of collapsing turnaround time for
getting results back
which is extremely valuable for these
businesses
the per test costs are in the middle
because there is a significant capital
investment required
and if we amortize that over three years
and apply it to the recurring costs it's
significant
you have the you also have the human
capital required to run the tests
and maintain the testing program if you
are not a high volume tester
traditional in-house testing isn't
really a feasible option
it should really be thought of as more
of a longer term investment
with the idea that eventually it will
save you money
with our hybrid testing program we're
able to offset a lot of the capital
expense by renting the hardware to our
clients in exchange for a nominal
integration and setup fee fee
since our clients are able to rely on us
for helping manage their testing program
we also offset a portion of the human
capital required to set up and maintain
an in-house testing program
these cost savings combine to offer the
lowest per test cost for policy testing
obviously since the system is in-house
you're doing the test yourself
you still have the benefit of the
collapse timeline for
for the for the turnaround
all time net cost comparison for a
three-year testing program so
here we modeled the three-year costs
associated with
the three testing programs the hybrid
program
and traditional in-house and commercial
testing
and we did this at six different testing
volumes ranging from 30 tests per month
to 600 tests per month
at the left we have the testing volume
broken down as test per month
then we show the retail price per test
we charge for the hybrid program and
then there is the total
three-year projected cost for the three
testing
options or the three testing program
options
two things jumped out from the analysis
one is if you are performing
less than 30 tests per month it makes
the most sense to just send samples off
to your favorite contract lab
the cost savings doesn't really start
until you get above this 25 to 30 test
per month threshold
and the second is if you are just
starting out to endeavor down the
in-house testing route
a hybrid testing program like the one we
described
is a great way to mitigate the risk of
moving testing in-house
it actually saves money and allows you
to lean on the expertise of your
commercial testing partner
all right net cost comparison for a
three-year testing program
for the visual learners out there we put
the same information in a bar graph
uh in gray we have a function of testing
volume the three-year cost associated
with using a third-party testing lab
in blue we have the cost associated with
undertaking in-house testing on your own
and in black we have the hybrid can id
testing program
the hybrid testing program lowers the
barrier to entry and saves money
on bulk potency testing the hybrid model
resembles a partnership for clients and
our clients get data and support they
need at an affordable price
and subject matter experts can leverage
their application expertise to help
facilitate the sustained success of
their clients
in-house testing program this makes
high-quality potency data more
accessible
to cannabis businesses all right
in summary here is as promised
a new hybrid laboratory testing model
was described to democratize chemical
potency testing
uh cannabis producers and processors
rely on analytical data to run their
business
these clients have unique in-house
testing needs due to the high volume of
potency testing they require
there is significant overlap in
centralized and decentralized testing
workflows
standardized hardware software and sops
can work together to help decentralize
chemical testing
more to help make decentralized chemical
testing more accessible
software allows centralized labs to
leverage subject matter expertise
and expand their professional laboratory
service offerings
and decentralized clients get the data
and support they need to bring testing
in-house
with that i want to thank you for
attending thank you labyrinths for
hosting
if you would like to connect please feel
free to email me directly at the email
address listed or reach out on linkedin
thank you